the antibody test that proved my wife
wrong back in April the spectator ran a
feature in which the partners of regular
contributors wrote about what it was
like being stuck in quarantine with the
likes of us what Caroline had to say
wasn't very flattering quote Toby spent
the first week of lockdown in bed
convinced he had coronavirus he didn't
he's a complete hypochondriac at the
best of times and this pandemic has sent
his anxiety levels through the roof he
was so worried about catching it that
the stress led to a bout of shingles
which is what actually laid him up
unquote ever since then I've been trying
to prove to her that I really did have
Co vid 19 but without success
for instance a well which I've got in
touch to tell me he was developing an
antibody test and would send me one if I
was happy to serve as a guinea pig in
his clinical trial if I had had it as I
claimed this would be a good way of
seeing if his tests worked but what if I
didn't have it I asked but you did have
it didn't you he said slightly surprised
yes yes of course
I asked him to send me six so I could
test Caroline and the children as well
and they duly arrived by courier
the following day technically it was a
lateral flow immuno assay which means
you had to prick your finger place a
drop of blood in the well of a little
plastic tray add a few drops of the
assay solution and then wait for the
result within a few minutes it would
tell you whether you had any
immunoglobulin M in your blood in which
case you were probably fighting off a
recent infection or immunoglobulin G
which suggests you'd had it some time
ago alternatively nothing would happen
indicating you've never had it I took
one of the plastic trays out of its
sealed packet you can only use them once
and did what was required
it works like a pregnancy test so once
you've submitted the sample you then
have to wait for the little line to
appear in the relevant place or not as
the case may be
Caroline was peering over my shoulder as
I stared at the little tray and the
children sat around the kitchen table
eagerly looking up at me it doesn't seem
to be
King I said giving it a vigorous shake
Caroline giggled and the children rolled
their eyes maybe I didn't use enough
blood I'm gonna try again
hang on said Caroline if you use another
one then we won't be able to test
ourselves can't be helped I said tearing
the next one open I'm the guinea pig
after all two hoots of laughter and
derision I pricked my finger again this
time much harder and dripped blood into
the well of the tray again nothing I
then tried another then another same
result every time eventually when I'd
used up five tests I offered that last
one to Caroline what's the point
she asked eyes shining with amusement it
obviously doesn't work ever since then
I've had to endure hours of what my
children call bands if I complain of
being tired or of having backache one of
them will say what's the matter dad
another bout of coronavirus then another
will join in want me to call an
ambulance get you on a ventilator even
Caroline chips in perhaps you should
take to your bed for a week like the
last time you had Cove in nineteen I on
to the hope that the tests I've been
sent were defective so when I saw that a
private testing facility had opened in
the headquarters of the Honourable
Artillery Company in the city and you
could get a bona fide MH RA approved
antibody test for 48 pounds I decided to
give it one last shot I got on the tube
on Monday making sure to wear my mask
and made my way to the testing center in
Moorgate it was very professional
staffed entirely by ex-army medics and
they assured me that their tests which
was similar to the one I'd taken at home
was 98% accurate I got the result within
10 minutes on my way back to the tube I
called Caroline looks like you're gonna
be eating humble pie this evening I said
she couldn't believe it but sure enough
I tested positive for immunoglobulin G
turns out it wasn't man flu after all
I'm a vegetarian she objected don't
worry I said there's no meat in humble
pie it's full of things that are really
good for you